Ironically, most of us are so afraid of being
alone that we actually end up isolating ourselves
trying to prevent it.
We all want the world to like us.
We all want to be the best we can be.
This is a noble goal to have, but when we
are so fearful that people won’t like us,
we begin to put effort towards something that
is intrinsically effortless.
We begin to relinquish our confidence and
personality to a character manufactured out
of fear and insecurity.
If you truly want others to enjoy being around
you, you must first dedicate your effort to
learning how to accept and enjoy YOURSELF.
By caring less about how others feel about
you, and more about how you feel about yourself,
you often become a much more likable person.
Your presence will be honest and real.
It will be infectious.
People will see you, rather than through you.
People who try to make others like them before
they like themselves act only out of insecurity
and fear and ultimately, all their attempts
at real connection lead back to insecurity
and fear.
For example, in a conversation, often the
harder you try, the less successful you are
at maintaining fluidity and enjoyableness.
A person who simply seeks to be themselves
will be both confident and comfortable.
If you are educated to any degree and have
lived at all, you have a unique and valuable
perspective of the world.
If you embrace and trust in it, you do not
have to work at being any character other
than your own.
A combination of Socrates’s philosophy,
“Know thyself,” and Emerson’s, “trust
thyself,” appear to solve many of the common
social problems that humans face.
Both quotes are based on “thyself,” and
this is no coincidence.
“Thyself” is the foundation to all personal
experiences, even when they involve others.
One who tries to avoid inadequate social interactions
will almost certainly create them.
One who is concerned that they are not going
to always say the right thing, will almost
certainly say the wrong thing.
One who simply is, IS and will always be a
happy and beautiful contributor to social
exchange.
Do not let your imagination create social
problems that do not exist.
The only purpose for sociality is to learn,
teach, connect, or have fun.
Conversations and relationships take on a
life of their own and you must let them fulfill
their purpose.
When you cease to solely identify with your
social interactions and, instead, let them
identify with you, they will be vibrant and
wondrous.